this is where my garage sale yard sale
Wine Library [__] 1991. get me some
tape and a Sharpie and I'll [__]
build you an Empire [__]
[Music]
Ed attention and build businesses
back a little bit yeah it's got wheels
on the back yeah
[Music]
team the nature of how much room we have
is not conducive to how many team
members we have so a lot of the time for
a lot of people is going to be to be at
the other table we have Addison sports
cards where we're going to set up a
whole thing we got to get rid of a lot
of these boxes and I think I want to
take them to Edison so we're going to
help to do that all right we need a lot
of help from you guys on this so eight
base 16 open sign 240 bucks what's up
brother
you sold it [__] really gone it's a
[__] beast
[__] love this card thanks for you
guys we've only seen about half the
dimensions interesting whole new section
that's massive me and AJ crushed it we
went around and just gave 30 40 50 slabs
to kids just being nice people are so
happy I think I'm giving away too many
like if I'm thinking now like one at a
time help me you got it we are at the
booth we're building three four five six
so 30 30 60 91 240 so we're gonna be 11
short who's got the key smelling
easy six easy right easy six I think
you're doing it right yep that's it
we're doing it like reading a book like
reading a book perfect that's it Corso's
taking control of something very
important he's gonna do build this wall
who's got the best handwriting here
James is confident I think it's so funny
Allison all right you and Allison are
doing a battle battle right now give me
the circle stickers 9.5 and 9 Dash with
the dollar amount I would like to see
how both of you do it oh James you won I
could see it already when you said it I
saw it yeah I did see a little
confidence in his eyes too okay you're
gonna do the pricing of the characters
all of these Corso have to be a 10. yeah
we have one yep that's right that's
right you guys are ready to go
inspirational thanks man on your ground
thank you brother real
take care of yourself ribs these are
ready to get graded right it's so
powerful as a visual
but that's exactly what happened
and what's in there
Zach this is garbage too yep let's get
it out these were the original drawings
then we had to convert them into
something I could do cartoons and toys
with only way these were available was
when you got the nft there was no other
way these wizard packs were selling for
20 bucks exclusive at the national I'm
gonna get you started with a beef
well we gotta get Germany into V friends
cards it's for you
you're welcome my brother needed how are
you good to see you series one is done
incredibly well and [__] series two
because of the nft market we're starting
to get our [__] together I think we
should put the play mat against these
right here and right here with a price
this way they don't take up all the
space like I think we should sell the
play match from here and literally tape
them here and have a price yep all right
this is where my ghetto garage sale yard
sale Wine Library [__] 1991. let's
get me some tape and a Sharpie and I'll
[__] build you an Empire [__]
yeah dude it's really happening like
you're gonna took a look on eBay and be
like what the [__] going on yeah I
need this to Edison Sports can anybody
execute it so we didn't really get that
many we got like 50 boxes out of there
was only a thousand made
to a thousand there's only a thousand of
them who did not know that and they
become a whole [__] thing
okay
all right let's go get organized on that
my man I got you it's for you thank you
have a good show
my man I got you what's up bro yeah
thank you appreciate it stay well bro
it's for you bro thank you figure out
what's going on there oh my God
is for you
thank you enjoy it that's for you for
you bro have a great show this show is
so much bigger I tell you what's up
brother it's great to see you again
could not appreciate you more thank you
bro and the show is enormous
we'll see you around hope you guys have
the best show where we're set up over
there in a big Way come back of course
one each
gotcha it's gonna get busy one for you
and one for you dragons legit
Cowboys legit
you can see them all on the wall they're
alphabetical let's see what the prices
are master bath yes I know who you are
brother yes I do brother I've been to
the trenches all the time yes I am
really yes dude I live in [__]
contest oh wow so if that grades of 10
it's 180 180 dollars
this is insane did you see this Brandon
it's not that big it's an audio
Jolly Jekyll And garyvee
I also like to compete
friends
this man owes you money oh okay I owe
you this okay I did what you said I was
a superintendent and I opened the shop
two months ago that's my first hand I
owe that to you I'm proud of you I
watched it all and I did it it took me
two years I'm proud of you brother thank
you I'll keep I will cherish this yes I
remember it's good to see you again this
is for you
I hope you have a great show okay you're
welcome
yo Rip's got that girl I hope you have a
great National
it makes me so happy this is just
amazing thank you brother thank you it's
great that read that team let's use this
as a moment till I gather our thoughts
what do we feel what do we need what are
we thinking like where are we at
where is that feedback coming from
people just hear it so we fill like pins
all in here I like okay pins please
and for you thank you so much can you
take advantage of that line right now
and hook up people whoever you think is
looking like just got it you know what
to do
one two three Brandon big trade all his
hits including some serious ones in
exchange for 20 minutes in New York he
crushed me on it but we need more ammo
for the kids watch this Andy boom thank
you
yeah all right
as a business owner I love it
so this went from common to like flying
on eBay think about what's happened to
this car in the last 48 hours this is a
good car brother
no oh no tens or two they're too hard to
get a grade
got it yeah I would this specific
Community has been incredibly supportive
and consistent and obviously I've been
very behind the scenes working working
working it's it's coming together it's
really coming together I hope
trade that for a Plinko board play over
there brother
all right yep um he's wearing a Bill's
Jersey make sure his Plinko board does
not do well
um anyway you know what the first one
created was you know what's funny I
brought that up the other day we
actually filmed recreating the whole
thing I don't actually know but we're
gonna go back and look at it I've
watched your like garage videos so they
started my car my card account it's
awesome brother there's only 55 wizard
Golds and it's in here I think it's in
there
thank you brother I love them I'm about
to go do one soon did you look these up
on eBay yet I haven't let's do it right
now go there right now and put three
friends super stickers completed I got
you
wow
wow wow
these guys have no idea
first guys should take sticker signs
thank you sure thank you for paying for
my VIP tickets
it's a big one brother I got the elf too
man so I've done all the successes I
love what you're doing man thank you
brother we're going to keep working here
we go my friend 60 over here you go in
cash or you go in Carter I'll take it
I'll take it yeah check this up on eBay
right now right now before I sign it you
need to fill it up uncompleted
device of course first of all make sure
you make your money in a proper way how
you make your money yes is more
important than how much money you make
that's the first [__] point second
try to make money on things you like
because when you like it you'll work
hard enough to make it happen
look at this kid look at this [__]
kid get over here Brandon look at this
dude why didn't you roll up like this
dude
just taking a photo
who's taking the photo I could do it
yeah all right all right that's great
that's been out whose camera
last summer I was going my first
national I'm like oh garyvee's going
to I want to give him something and I
made you this and then on the way to the
show you're like so long I'm heading to
Germany
will you sign yes my new tattoo whoa oh
wait where's the camera pretty epic
brother pretty [__] Epic
I asked you why'd you left your family's
business and then you told me something
and I did it I started my own company in
May and I've done more and safe than I
ever did in life I remember that day in
Macy's very well brother think about how
you feel now versus two years ago
now think what's going to be hit in two
years in two years it's gonna burn and
eventually you're gonna burst I remember
very vividly I'm proud of you I saw you
in line yeah and I saw your face I'm
like I think this [__] guy jumped
wow
[Music]
any advice podcasting chopping pieces of
it yeah to put out on social where
you'll get awareness yes and reaching
out to bigger guests that you think you
can get and hoping one says yes
we're really happy with the way it's
going very nice step by step a real
pleasure meeting you bro come here
what are you doing here where are we
right now I really want to create this
world an intellectual property I did it
through an nft launch but I also do
trading cards along the way series one
and series two yes compete and collect
which is the predominant execution we're
doing here is a trading card game we
launched our game format we have a big
tournament this weekend so collectible
card it's an intellectual property think
of it as Pokemon meets
um Sesame Street
where's Dustin I grew all these I threw
every one of these wow and then when we
knew that we were gonna make animated
films and cartoons and take it to the
next level I converted them from this to
this that's so very cool yep thanks
again
I know who you are brother it's a
pleasure Legend a pleasure pleasure
really one of the 10 best hockey players
of all time smart you won thank you stay
well have a great show
[__] go eight bucks for all that I
need you in the [__] be friends game
do you know many people lack Common
Sense oh my God
so I [__] with common sense do [__] you
love that will always work out tons of
[__] I do doesn't work but as long as
I'm not dead it gives me a chance to do
something else and I just want to keep
doing stuff I want and some people like
me like to do a lot of things you might
want to just do one thing it's all good
but just like it because you're gonna
[__] die and then what thank you so
much of course they're all wizards
bubble gum bubble gum [__] grown men
getting upset about Bubble team we're
gonna have to wrap it up because they're
gonna kick us out and we gotta lock up
and I want to figure out our strategy so
let's let's be nice
Gary be epic tomorrow
who's got the key Gary B epic whoa yeah
it's gone I'm a little bit upset about
that I told you that yeah I know but I'm
still sad there's only 25 of them I just
want to say thank you I just my team has
been raving the the the work speaks for
itself all right let's wrap it up let's
wrap it up Team all right day one in the
books we are building this intellectual
property Rome is not built in a day it's
something you hear a lot at this point
in my career and some of you might be
feeling this pressure because I've had a
lot of successes people expect every new
thing for me to happen immediately but
that's not how it works it takes time
but it's very clear to me what we're
building here and more importantly
seeing the smiles on kids faces I think
we'll look back at these early days of
doing this and uh I'm enjoying it I'm
really enjoying it working hard so big
day then it's just Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday and Sunday still left
feet
[Music]